>> IF I COULD HAVE ONE WISH,
IT WOULD BE THIS ONE.
I WISH MY ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES WOULD
GET (BLEEP) DONE.
WE THINK IF YOU JUST TRIED YOU
COULD MAKE GET ALONG AND THAT IS
WHY WE ARE LAUNCHING HASHTAG
FUCO WITH THIS SONG.
WON'T YOU (BLEEP)ING COOPERATE?
(BLEEP)ING COOPERATE.
SURE YOU ARE GREEDY,
RACIST, SEXIST, SELFISH AND
CORRUPT, WE KNOW.
CAN YOU BE LIKE PRINCESS ELSA
AND (BLEEP)ING JUST LET IT GO.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS KIND OF CRAZY.
WE KNOW IT IS NOT THE NORM.
BUT IF WE ALL WORK TOGETHER FOR
JUST A WEE BIT OF REFORM.
(BLEEP) COOPERATE!
>> HEAR IT ON FACEBOOK.
LIKE IT ON TWITTER.
RETWEET ME. DOUBLE TAP ME ON
INSTAGRAM.
SWIPE RIGHT ON TINDER. PIN IT TO
MY MEERKAT
AND PLEASE
WRITE YOUR SENATOR.